So how does clustering work?
The first step in
clustering is to define
the distance between
two data points.
The most popular way
to compute the distance
is what's called
Euclidean distance.
This is the standard
way to compute distance
that you might have seen before.
Suppose we have
two data points-- I
and J. The distance
between the two points,
which we'll call Dij, is
equal to the square root
of the difference
between the two
points in the first component,
squared, plus the difference
between the two points
in the second component,
squared, all the way up to
the difference between the two
points in the k-th
component, squared,
where k here is the
number of attributes
or independent variables.
Let's see how this works
by looking at an example.
In our movie lens dataset,
we have binary vectors
for each movie, classifying
that movie into genres.
The movie Toy Story
is categorized
as an animation, comedy,
and children's movie.
So the data for
Toy Story has a 1
in the spot for these three
genres and a 0 everywhere else.
The movie Batman Forever is
categorized as an action,
adventure, comedy,
and crime movie.
So Batman Forever has a 1 in
the spot for these four genres
and a 0 everywhere else.
So given these two
data observations,
let's compute the
distance between them.
So the distance, d, would
be equal to the square root
of (0-0)^2 + (0-1)^2 + (0-1)^2
+ (1-0)^2 , 1 et cetera.
This ends up being equal
to the square root of 5.
In addition to
Euclidean distance,
there are many other
popular distance
metrics that could be used.
One is called Manhattan
distance, where the distance is
computed to be the sum of
the absolute values instead
of the sum of square.
Another is called maximum
coordinate distance,
where we only consider the
measurement for which the data
points deviate the most.
Another important
distance that we
have to calculate for
clustering is the distance
between clusters, when a cluster
is a group of data points.
We just discussed how to
compute the distance between two
individual points,
but how do we compute
the distance between
groups of points?
One way of doing
this is by using
what's called the
minimum distance.
This defines the
distance between clusters
as the distance between the
two data points in the clusters
that are closest together.
For example, we would
define the distance
between the yellow
and red clusters
by computing the Euclidean
distance between these two
points.
The other points in the clusters
could be really far away,
but it doesn't matter if
we use minimum distance.
The only thing we care about is
how close together the closest
points are.
Alternatively, we could
use maximum distance.
This one computes the distance
between the two clusters
as the distance
between the two points
that are the farthest apart.
So for example, we would
compute the distance
between the yellow
and red clusters
by looking at these two points.
Here, it doesn't matter how
close together the other points
are.
All we care about is how close
together the furthest points
are.
The most common distance
metric between clusters
is called centroid distance.
And this is what we'll use.
It defines the distance
between clusters
by computing the
centroid of the clusters.
The centroid is
just the data point
that takes the average of all
data points in each component.
This takes all data points
in each cluster into account
and can be thought of as
the middle data point.
In our example, the centroids
between yellow and red
are here, and we would
compute the distance
between the clusters
by computing
the Euclidean distance
between those two points.
When we are computing
distances, it's
highly influenced by the
scale of the variables.
As an example, suppose
you're computing the distance
between two data points,
where one variable is
the revenue of a company
in thousands of dollars,
and another is the age
of the company in years.
The revenue variable
would really
dominate in the
distance calculation.
The differences between
the data points for revenue
would be in the thousands.
Whereas the differences
between the year variable
would probably be less than 10.
To handle this, it's customary
to normalize the data first.
We can normalize by subtracting
the mean of the data
and dividing by the
standard deviation.
We'll see more of
this in the homework.
In our movie data set,
all of our genre variables
are on the same scale.
So we don't have to
worry about normalizing.
But if we wanted to add a
variable, like box office
revenue, we would
need to normalize
so that this variable didn't
dominate all of the others.
Now that we've defined how
we'll compute the distances,
we'll talk about a specific
clustering algorithm--
hierarchical clustering--
in the next video.